we turn now to a murder mystery after
the discovery of not one but two bodies
found when the water level in lake mead
dropped dramatically and it immediately
raised suspicions for anyone who knows
anything about the mafia or just watched
the godfather
two sets of human remains were
discovered in lake mead they think it
screams mob activity right now
investigators trying to figure out who's
remained paddle boaters found at lake
mead police telling us there's no
evidence of foul play here but it begs
the question how many more bodies will
be found now that the lake is at record
low levels well all of this has been the
talk of legal circles and mob circles
and we're joined now by oscar goodman
the former mayor of las vegas who for
years represented an assortment of
organized crime figures mr goodman thank
you for being here i bet the phone's
been ringing off the hook with these
discoveries you know i can't even leave
my home
uh without being asked who did it and
who was it
uh if i knew i wouldn't tell you
any hints suggestions
well i don't think that it was
necessarily a mob hit
i wish that we had uh the caliber of uh
bullet that was involved
the 22 was the bullet of choice back in
those days of alleged mobsters
and uh i'd like to
see whether it was a 22 and also find
out the entry
that the the bullet made
that would be important because
the technique that they used back in
those days was to shoot somebody in the
back of the head
the other thing of course
it would be nice to have the dna
i'm sure they're going to get to that
point and it may be able to identify who
the person is through that process
uh but right now we're just speculating
and enjoying the fact that it took place
uh in las vegas
it involved a uh what would appear to be
a mob hit although it was not the type
of uh
mob activity that took place back then
there was sort of a
an unwritten rule that if somebody were
killed by the the mob
uh they would be killed in uh california
or in arizona uh because they didn't
want to bring the attention of the
justice department into las vegas since
uh bobby kennedy was very interested in
making sure that las vegas was white
from the face of the earth
among your clients with anthony the aunt
spelatro who apparently was alleged to
have killed between 22 and 27 people uh
does this have his trademark
uh no uh
you know it's interesting that's what
the allegation was i represented tony
for many many years
and the fbi always used to say how can
you represent a guy who killed 27 people
i said how could you
even say that to me when he never spent
a day in jail the only time he spent in
jail is waiting for me to get through
with the case so i could get him out on
bail but never convicted of anything so
uh
you know he was portrayed by joe pesci
in the movie casino of which i was one
of the stars by the way but i knew how
to keep the bosses happy whenever they
gave me little jobs to do you know to
send a message i would carry things out
to
a t it doesn't smell even like what they
uh alleged
that spellacho was involved in it's a
big desert out there and you went to a
lot of trouble to put somebody in a
barrel
and then take them out into the lake and
throw them into the water uh that's a
lot of trouble all you had to do
is uh go someplace which was uh nuts uh
too far from the the urban area here uh
have a big shovel take a big hole and
throw a body in it and that would
accomplish the same thing probably more
effectively than how it turned out
could it be jimmy hoffa
i i doubt that to be quite frank with
you uh the reason i say that the only uh
news that i got of any substance
was that the clothing
that the the student was wearing
uh was from kmart
and if jimmy hoffa was buying his
clothes from kmart i'm a monkey's uncle
so this is focused attention again on
your beloved city and the organized
crime background that's just part of
history now isn't it
uh it is uh there's there's no mob here
now uh a lot at all no there really
isn't uh well
sometimes i i think some of these uh
oh holier than now fellas who run the
casinos here
uh do things that the bob wouldn't even
think of doing but
as far as the
the mob
as fictionalized in the movies like
casino or
goodfellas movies of that nature
they don't exist anymore the concept of
omerta the silence of uh the uh quote
mafia end quote uh is no longer it's no
longer followed in any of these cases
they can't wait to get in line and make
the best deal by being the first one who
in effect squeals on it
is las vegas a better place now without
the mob is there something about the
romanticized mystique of those gangsters
that's missing
i like the old days better for a lot of
reasons in the old days a man's uh
a handshake was his bond and nothing had
to be in writing now everything is put
down in contractual form and
um a man's word isn't good anymore and
that's a shame they were characters we
don't have the characters anymore um if
a fella had a
a hunchback for instance they
weren't shy about calling him the camel
or hunchy
uh if he was left-handed like the
character portrayed by de niro uh in the
movie casino uh they referred to him as
lefty uh tony they called him the ant um
a fella up in
massachusetts that i represented uh
vinnie at the animal they called him but
not to his face which is uh
important to note
so uh we'll folly find out from dna
whose bodies have been found in the lake
uh are you eager to find out
i i really uh
as a matter of interest you know it's
it's an interesting
uh situation you don't ordinarily find
bodies in a lake but
i'm sure they never
expected when the body was placed in the
lake that it would be discovered but the
lake has
gone down so
so far
that nobody could have anticipated that
just as a matter of interest am i going
to say hooray no
you know this is a murder case it
obviously wasn't suicide it's a murder
case so
the person who was killed probably had
the people who loved him more
you would hope so anyway everybody needs
a little love
and uh whoever killed him uh probably is
no longer with us it's been so long ago
all right oscar goodman former mayor of
las vegas uh
esteemed and widely recognized lawyer of
some real characters thank you so much
for being with us here all right thank
you so much
all right mr oscar goodman up next this
week's winners and losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aiden
you've chosen as your winner this week
chris wallace who left fox for cnn plus
only to see cnn plus get cancelled well
now his boss at cnn chris look has
announced they found a place for him
a big part of the cnn brand is
respectful authentic and impactful
interviews and one of the best
interviewers in the business is chris
wallace we are excited to announce that
who's talking to chris wallace will
return to production this fall with
episodes on hbo max and on our cnn
linear channel
do a new job for chris wallace who
apparently is getting paid 9 million a
year by cnn that's right so now this uh
winner i should note has a lot of
caveats uh chris wallace joined cnn plus
from fox news uh where he spent 20 years
as the anchor of fox news sunday he was
supposed to be sort of the flagship
journalist of the new streaming platform
as we both know cnn plus shuttered
after just a couple weeks on the air
now chris wallace has found a home uh
he's being his show who's talking to
chris wallace is going to be aired on
hbo max which is now under the same
umbrella as cnn as part of warner bros
discovery this new conglomerate it's
also going to be airing on sunday nights
on cnn um so while a lot of the
journalists that went over to cnn plus
um were sort of up in the air and are
not sure about their future chris
wallace can be sure that he has a place
at cnn the biggest win here and i think
why we we ended up choosing chris
wallace's uh our winner this week uh is
one number uh that i want to give you
here brian that's 76.8 million and that
is the number of subscribers that hbo
max has where who's talking to chris
wallace is going to be airing that blows
any other network streaming platform out
of the water and that's really why he's
a winner today but he made the right
move you think even with all this
happened uh you know i think when he
said why he left fox news there were
reasons beyond just the opportunity at
cnn plus he thought that fox news had
gotten far too extreme and pro-trump uh
for his taste um so i think he's
certainly happy to have left fox news
and have gone to this new opportunity um
the fact that he's going to be on cnn
he's going to be an anchor for cnn as
well no doubt doing the big news nights
for the network um and especially with
that salary which you noted earlier um
i'm sure he's pretty happy with the
situation right now all right and for
the loser this week you've chosen
someone from fox news tucker carlson who
has been proponent of what's called the
great replacement theory of baseless
conspiracy theory
you've heard a lot about the great
replacement theory recently it's
everywhere in the last two days and
we're still not sure exactly what it is
here's what we do know for a fact there
is a strong political component to the
democratic party's immigration policy
we're not guessing this we know this and
we know it because they have said so
well this took on residents given that
was raised placement theory was cited by
the shooter in buffalo last weekend
right and there you have tucker carlson
saying he doesn't actually know what
great replacement theory is which is uh
nonsense because tucker carlson has
spent the last couple of years promoting
great replacement theory on his show
which is a sort of white nationalist
theory
that holds that elites are importing
immigrants from south america
in order to gain electoral advantage for
democrats and effectively replace the
white race in america thereby the
replacement um it's a uh theory that was
mostly confined to the fever swamps of
4chan and other white nationalist white
supremacist websites for years until
tucker carlson
revived it he got a huge amount of
criticism for doing so um and it has
actually inspired a series of mass
shootings including the el paso shooting
where the gunman wanted to target uh
hispanic people and now recently the
buffalo shooting where
the alleged shooter is believed to have
targeted
people of color
so you know at the end of the day tucker
carlson makes a lot of excuses
for why this theory that he's promoting
is not inspiring these shootings
but i think you know occam's razor a
series of mass shootings have happened
that are inspired by this white
nationalist theory that is being
promoted by the most watched uh host on
fox news and all of cable news i think
we can conclude that there's a problem
there and as you know the demographics
of america are changing what's different
here is this theory that there's some
conspiracy by uh democrats to do it so
they get more voters right so the the
difference here is that obviously we
know that immigration and declining
birth rates among white population in
the united states changes the racial
demographics of the united states and
and the rest of the world
the theory here and the reason why it's
espoused by so many white nationalists
is that there's this cabal of elites
that are conspiring to import these
voters to change the racial makeup of
the united states usually the jews are
blamed for this
so that's what makes it a white
nationalist theory and that's why when
tucker carlson espouses it it creates
such an outrage and the fact that he
continues to do that the murdochs don't
seem to mind
no and you know chuck schumer uh the new
york senator sent a letter to rupert
murdoch and the leadership at fox news
uh basically begging them to put a stop
to tucker cross and promoting this
theory on his show it's unclear that
that's going to be successful at all ed
mclaughlin thank you so much for joining
thanks all of you for joining us we'll
see you back here again next week on the
law and crime trial network
[Applause]
you